[Music]
no hesitating here joe jonas and sophie
turner are all in when it comes to their
love story i'm pumped i'm ready to
celebrate five years of knowing each
other the lovebirds went on a romantic
date and lucky for us joe decided to
vlog it and share the highlights at a
sweet video posted to tick tock
[Music]
the couple is absolutely speaking our
language here there's a stunning sunset
chic fall attire plenty of wine
delicious pasta a chocolate treat and a
handheld stroll true love at its finest
what more could you want
well turns out it gets even cuter are
you blushing oh god yeah or i'm sweaty i
can't tell if the song you heard sounds
familiar it's because it is that's
hesitate by none other than the jonas
brothers
[Music]
joe co-wrote the track and opened up
about the special meaning behind it in
the band's amazon prime documentary
happiness continues
hesitate
is a song i wrote
it's like my vows before i wrote my vows
it's my promise to sophie for me i
it takes me to a whole different
universe i'm seeing her walk down the
aisle again every time i close my eyes
when i sing hesitate i close my eyes for
half the song
cause i'm singing it to her
i have to find my sense of
home but joe and sophie they're a couple
who can do both
[Music]
the lovebirds traded romance for some
high-energy fun in this video joe shared
earlier this month during the jonas
brothers boston tour stop joe tapped
into his tick-tock husband skills and
filmed sophie strutting down the stage
his caption eat it up
[Music]
whether they're gushing over one another
or leaning into their goofy sides no
doubt this couple is head over heels
here's what sophie told et in 2019 about
her man when they stepped out together
to the game of thrones season premiere
it means so much to have him here it's
just like the best support the best
person to calm me down and keep me calm
and if i end up crying i have a shoulder
to cry on so it's good i'm so happy that
he's here
you